I think in fourth grade my parents took
me to watch the first Harry Potter movie
and then I got started getting into it.
Talked to my family members who were in
America and they sent me books. At the
same time, you know, there's all this
the sleep paralysis and then the demons.
I think around 20 22 I was laying down
and woke up and I was paralyzed and
there is this lady while I was holding a
knife. Did you think that you might die
that night?
Welcome, Michelle.
>> You were actually discussing some of the
things that happened in your life that
were kind of uh interesting from a a
spiritualism standpoint, I guess we
would say, from uh from uh things
happening that were kind of tormenting
you. Um and so I was going to kind of go
through some of that um and kind of see
what your thoughts were about it. Okay.
So then kind of growing up, uh it sounds
like you had a little bit of a mixed
background. You had a Protestant side.
Yes.
>> And then you also had a Catholic side of
your upbringing.
>> But so and there's a lot of spiritual
stuff um with the Catholic part of that.
>> Okay. So kind of define that. What do
you mean by there's a spiritualism?
>> No. Well, I I think it depends on what c
in what Catholic country you are from,
but in the Philippines there's a lot of
beliefs and you know monsters and and
they call it asang which is like witches
and there's a lot of mythologies of
different things like that. Is this just
like in the native culture basically?
>> I think so. Yes. But it it seeps into
whatever you know whatever religion you
are in. So it always finds its way to to
Catholicism. It's
>> do they do things that like try to
appease like you know make the spirits
not like come around and like it's an
active part of
>> Yes. I think so. You know you whenever
you're turning around and then oh my
goodness I'm passing by this dark part
of the woods. Let me make sure that I'm
polite. Um, and we say, you know, po
just so that we appease the spirits.
>> And everyone's Catholic there. So, you
would think because you're Christian
that you really wouldn't want to deal
with, you know, appeasing demons or
spirits like that, but that's just the
culture.
>> Is is Centuria also part of that
Philippines? That's more South America,
>> I think. So, I never really heard of it
before, but there's got to be elements
of it, you know, that
>> that's kind of similar, I think. M
>> so you kind of grew up um in this kind
of a little bit of a mixed belief
between parents, that type thing. And
then you went to a Protestant school.
Southern is a Protestant school.
>> Um and you started having a little bit
better relationship with Jesus. But you
were telling me kind of previously that
you started reading books or you'd had
been reading books that were probably
not something that a Christian would
>> No. You know, I was an avid reader. Even
like when I was in third grade, I think
I I started getting um uh little it's
not like a library card. You rent from
this, you know, individual like little
bookshop and I would rent like Archie's
stories, you know, little comic books
and then you get tired of that and you
want something more exciting. And then I
think in fourth grade my parents took me
to watch um the first Harry Potter movie
and that was amazing.
>> Your parents did?
>> My parents did. But they weren't like I
didn't grow up reading the Bible. We
didn't we you know sometimes we'd pray
before before um before eating and my
mom would invite me to read the rosary
and I would fall asleep halfway. Um but
yeah, my parents took me they just saw
it as benign fun. You know what a treat.
We drove 2 hours to go watch this film.
>> And this is in the Philippines.
>> Oh yes Philines 2 hours. We rode the
bus. Yeah.
No theater in your hometown?
>> Not in our hometown. No. And so it was
such a treat. And then I got started
getting into it. Talked to my family
members who were in America and they
sent me books and I'm like, "Oh my
goodness, how how exciting." And so, um,
yeah, that was where it really started.
>> Wow. Interesting.
>> Wow. Yeah. I I um I sort of grew up on
Harry Potter, too.
>> Yes. Um, I didn't grow up Christian. My
mom was raised Christian, but she had
left the church, like just like slowly,
you know, faded away from the church at
some point, but always kind of like
believed there was a God. And so I
believe there was a God, but didn't know
God. Anyway, so I uh yeah, I I remember
watching Harry Potter, the first Harry
Potter film, for the first time at a
friend's house. They introduced me to it
>> and then it became a big thing. So, like
we would get Harry Potter books from the
library and we would read them and then
we'd watch the movies as a family and
then we would, you know, play the video
games and and doing like all of the
singing all the spells out loud and
stuff and Yeah. And then doing the
little motions.
>> Yeah, that was a big thing at the time.
>> How many Harry Potter books are there?
>> Seven. Seven.
>> Seven. I didn't know that books. I mean,
they're like this thing like how many
pages? Well, this the last one was
upwards of 700.
>> Wow.
>> 700 pages. Yes. How many pages are in
this thing?
>> Well,
>> 700 pages.
>> Well, that's small. That's small print,
though.
>> Okay. There's there's roughly what 8 or
900 pages in the Old Testament. 900
almost a thousand.
>> It's a commitment to read it.
>> Okay. So, there's about 2,000.
>> But on top of that, there's also other
like like what do you call it like
offshoots from Harry Potter, right? like
other franchises like uh Fantastic
Beasts and Where to Find Them and all of
those other ones?
>> No, I just I think it was an I was at an
older time. So, I watched and read Harry
Potter in elementary school and then in
high school and then college, you know,
that was the end of an era, right? It
was the end of the movie franchise and
it kind of got started into Twilight and
then Vampires. Oh, blood suckers. Just
benign stuff. I mean, I've been
watching, you know, different
mythological characters kill each others
on the film and then the witches and
stuff like that. So, it's it's a phase,
I think, you know, depending on where
you are in life. I was a teenager and
then Twilight is all about the teenage
teenagers romance. Yes. And then later
on, you started getting more interested
in other things like, oh, you know what?
I found myself reading a whole book
about the literal devil Hades. And it's
just like, wow, this needs to be this
needs to stop at some point.
>> Yeah.
>> You know, Twi Twilight especially, like
you mentioned the romance part of it,
it's always like this like you know, you
know, oh, it's this love story that's
put together, but if you really think
about it, it's like the on a spectrum of
love, right? Um love is very giving. Uh
that's why for God so loved the world
that he gave his only begotten son,
right? It's a it's a doing something for
someone else, right? where you think
about the type of love that comes out of
Twilight is very I'm going to take
something from you. I'm if if I actually
suck your blood or whatever, I'm gonna
like actually take your life and you're
going to be done. And that's the
opposite end of the spectrum, right?
What I do is going to kill you. Like
that story is such a twisted view of
what love really is. It's actually like
built on lust, which lust is let me take
something from you.
>> Oh yes. And I think a lot of women in
our generation now looking back on it
realizes that that was quite a toxic
relationship. We probably shouldn't have
been reading that when we were 15.
>> Yeah. I wonder I wonder what that does
to your actual relationships in life.
>> Oh, you know that's true. I I grew up
reading it when I was um 17 18 and that
was before I ever had any boyfriend. So
I'm just glad I met the husband that I
have now who's not anything like that.
So wait, so as a Catholic, you know,
you're obviously aware of spiritual
warfare.
>> Oh yes.
>> So as a Adventist as well, you're also
aware of the sort of great controversy
ideas. Were you recognizing those within
the books? And did you have thoughts
about that? Like, oh my goodness, like
they're they're literally talking about
like such evil things. And
>> yes, you know, it it really only clicked
in my early 30s in my adulthood, I
guess, when I was reading my Bible. M
hey right here. Best book in the world.
This will straighten anyone out.
>> Cuz there was a time they were, you
know, we would go to church and then we
have the rest of Sabbath, the rest of
Saturday and Sunday. You would literally
go to church and you go back to what you
were doing. You know, read the books
that I was reading. It's like it's just
for fun. It's harmless. In my mind, it's
like I can separate these two. I can
read my Bible in the evening and then
read this throughout the day. But then
the more you read and read the Bible,
the more discernment you have, the more
your eyes are open, the more
>> convictions you get. And so, yeah, that
was when I decided
>> maybe I should get rid of them.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, but you know, that's the thing is
that by beholding, we become changed.
Oh,
>> true. And so, the thing is is thank God
that reading the Bible can be more
transformative than any other book in
the world. But if we read books that are
like that and you know I remember uh I
was given as a child some of the Harry
Potter books. But my parents looked at
them and they said we really don't want
you reading this. We'll we'll take this
we'll take this away. You're not going
to read this. And this was when I was a
kid. This is like when they first came
out.
>> But then later on I was curious. I had
seen, you know, some of the the some
clips from like the first movie or
something like that and I was like, man,
like and I think I I got uh I never
actually physically got the book, but I
downloaded the the the audiobook version
>> and I just started listening to it
>> and it was just such such a happy escape
basically like you could sit there, turn
your brain off and listen to that and
let your mind wander in this fantasy
land
>> and you know at the end of the day I'm
beholding something that is not for my
best interest. Right.
>> That's right.
>> Um and so you have to realize that the
devil creates some of this stuff not
because he's trying to go and get you to
do anything major, but just distract
you,
>> just just kind of prevent you.
>> But the thing is is there's some evils
there that can lead to changes in your
life that many people don't even really
think about.
>> Not at all. And you know why the Bible
describes them as familiar spirits? M
>> you are familiarizing
yourself with them
>> and it's almost like the the the the
commercial for them, right? You're
you're kind of seeing this thing that's
like, you know, ah they're not as bad as
as as they as everyone says they were.
Now, I have a question for you because
you grew up in the church.
>> Yes.
>> Were you a Bible reader a lot?
>> Uh you know, um that dropped off. I
didn't start reading these books until I
was off on my own. I I was like in
college, like a freshman or or sophomore
in college, and I would go out and one
of the things I'd like to do is, you
know, you're all stressed about classes
and like trying to get good grades and
everything else. And I like to go
walking and so I would sit there and I'd
put in my headphones and I'd have these
books and it would just be like, man, I
just going to want to go turn my brain
off type thing.
>> And I would go walk and I'm like, well,
I'm getting exercise
>> and I would say to myself,
>> well, I know it's not true. Which I'm
sure like that's what you're saying,
right?
>> Like I know it's not rationaliz. And so
you rationalize it like well I can
listen to I mean all these other people
might be deceived but I'm not deceived
right which is like such a naive way of
looking at it right
>> and such a superior way of looking at it
>> because you know like I didn't buy the
capes I didn't go to Harry Potter world
I can separate myself from this so I can
consume it
>> but no it's it's it's in your brain.
>> You didn't have a wand.
>> I did not. I just grabbed a stick.
>> Did you have a wand?
>> No.
>> I had an imaginary wand.
But what what other because I know that
so you did Harry Potter then Twilight
like what did you go to next after that?
>> Oh goodness. So you know as you become
more of a an older woman you started
reading into you know what's what's all
these like fantasy books and I started
getting into um a little book club that
I made up with my friends and oh yeah
you know let's read all these other
books that are called um this is Sarah
J. Moss. Um, there's like three
different trilogies or or not trilogies,
but there's different collections of
these books. I had all of them, you
know, like I spent hundreds of dollars
on books and and and um you know, like
the special covers, you know, the little
the little special um stickers that
would go with them, the little special
um artwork that would go with them. But
yeah, I read these books and they had
also, you know, witches and demons and
they're the good guys.
>> They are the good guys. And so, and then
in one of the books, the angels are
quite literally the bad, evil, blood
sucking people.
>> Wow.
>> Like, maybe there's just something
there. Maybe, maybe not. But I'm still
kind of on the fence there, you know,
where I'm still reading my Bible, but
not really as much, you know, reading it
to feel good by by seeing what Jesus
did, you know, all the the fluffy stuff
that that's just everything that I'm
absorbing. So I'm reading that in the
evening and reading my books and and
then I started you know having more
conviction and my husband and I decided
one day are we going to keep being
lukewarm or are we going to just go
allin
>> you know and then and then a lot of more
convictions started with that you know
we gave up a lot of things a lot of
sinful things and started really
celebrating
>> um you know everything that that Christ
gave us you know like a like a restful
full day, you know, going to church,
actually reading the Bible, praying
together. And the more I did that, the
more I felt convicted that maybe I
should stop, but oh, my friends and I
are reading. And you were at a book
club, right? Yes. My little friends and
I, we would exchange books. We would buy
we would go to little um we would go to
they're called red fairs.
>> Um but we would go and dress up. And I
remember Oh, you know.
>> Wait, wait. What? What's this fair? You
said the red fairs. What is that? fair.
It's a Renaissance fair.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Oh, well, I thought you guys were like
dressing up like Harry Potter characters
or something. Okay.
>> But there's your want.
>> Yes, it is. But no, but in this Renaare,
I bought a cauldron.
>> Seriously?
>> Yeah.
>> And you'd cook your soups and stuff in
it?
>> I bought a small cauldron to go with the
books that I was reading. And
>> Oh, wow.
>> And then I bought a dragon.
>> Interesting.
>> And it's just like, what am I doing? Did
you put him in the cauldron?
>> That's where he belongs to.
>> I should have thrown in the five,
>> but no. Um I think around 20 22 and my
husband and I decide, you know, we
really should just go all in. And I was
I was pulling myself back. I really
don't want to lose my friends and the
fun that we have with the books that we
read.
>> But at the same time, you know, there's
all these other things going on with my
life. And then and then the the sleep
paralysis and then the demons that I
felt like were just in the back of my
mind whenever I would read something
that was so
dark.
>> So wait, let's back up. So you were you
were talking about sleep paralysis
there. Yes.
>> Okay. So you started actually having
things happen as a result of reading
these books or while you were reading
these books.
>> While I was reading them, I was getting
in.
So when you get sleep paralysis, it's
either you're just paralyzed or there's
also some kind of being in the room with
you. And I would it's like my brain
would get inspiration and would pull
inspiration from what I'm listening, you
know, in like podcasts
>> and what I would what I was reading. So
it would it was getting more and more
graphic because I've had sleep paralysis
since I was elementary school, high
school age.
So you're laying in bed. Do you realize
that? So you you're awake at this point.
>> Yes. So typically with sleep paralysis,
you know, like the word says, you're
paralyzed cuz you're you're the your
body paralyzes you to keep out
>> you act keeping you from sleepwalking.
It's keeping you from doing all the the
the actions that you're you're doing in
your mind.
>> And so I've had this for forever, but it
would definitely
>> So you would wake from sleep basically
>> and you're like paralyzed like you can't
move.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. Okay. And then what do you see?
>> A figure.
>> A figure somewhere. Sometimes it's on
top of me. Sometimes it's just laying
there with its little tendrils of hair
kind of close by my my my body. Um
sometimes it's just in the corner, you
know, and I can't move
>> menacingly. Yeah.
>> Yeah. And does it talk?
>> No, it never talks. It's literally just
letting me know its presence was there.
>> So you felt like so it was like this
like malevolent kind of like
>> it I knew that it there's this feeling
that it wants to do harm and so there's
this very specific one that I had my
husband and I used to listen to this
podcast called myths and legends and it
would go around you know talking about
different urban legends mythologies
um from all over the world.
>> Yeah. And there was a specific one um
where it was it was a a story set in
Japan and I don't even really remember
the story but the very next day that
that night I was laying down and I woke
up and I was paralyzed and there's this
lady wearing a yucata which is a summer
kimono.
>> Okay. And like a Japanese kind of
>> like a Japanese attire. Yes. And I was
very um it's a very set apart from all
the other ones that were around me
because it was wearing something
>> cuz usually it's just a shadow
>> while it was holding a knife.
>> Oh wow.
>> And it was holding a knife and it was
just watching me.
>> And you woke up to this.
>> I Well, you were
>> Or was it like in a dream or like what
was it like?
>> She's paralyzed.
>> I'm paralyzed. And it is it's like yes
you're paralyzed and you're just looking
at it but you are in a dream and you try
to get yourself out of it by moving.
>> So you're not awake awake. It's not like
>> it's like it's a it's yeah it's not like
this. It's it's it's that
>> it's like a twilight zone kind of
>> I'm not sure
>> like kind of or not twilight zone but
like kind of like half in half out like
you're kind of like
>> I think so. But I know that if I try to
move my my fingers or or any of my
digits that I can kind of move and get
out of it. Sometimes I would be, you
know, making noises and my husband would
wake me up and he's like, "Oh, you're
you're you were moaning and kind of
grumbling. In my head, I was shouting
with all my might trying to wake up."
And the only thing he could hear was
>> Oh, wow. But yeah, just trying to get
out of it because I don't want this lady
to get close to me,
>> right?
>> Did you think that you might die that
night?
>> You know, there's always this assurance
in my mind that this is just a dream.
This is just a dream. But it didn't make
it any less scary.
>> It still feels very real.
>> It feels very real. And so I think at
that point my husband and I decided
maybe we should just not listen to this
scary podcast.
And so you know that that dwindled off
and then but I was still reading all the
other things and so
>> now um family history and it's okay if
you don't want to share but um does your
family have a history of maybe
spiritualism or getting involved in any
kind of
>> Yes. But there is too much to get into
>> any witchcraft or
>> no witchcraft. But my family definitely
believed in ghosts and you know seeing
um
>> nobody went to a witch doctor or a
spiritualist or a seance or you know
>> no I didn't even know what a seance was
until I I watched this movie um coming
here but no not not that much but you
know it was there was definitely some
some feeling that you know we because we
were Catholic we believe that if you die
then you either go straight to hell or
you go to heaven or if you're stuck then
and you feel unrest then your spirit
will be going around right and so there
was definitely this feeling that oh you
know if if you if you pass by and
there's this you know this there's this
forest or there's this dark corner in
your house maybe it was your grandpa cuz
he died in here then you know he was
trying to make himself known and so
there was definitely that feeling but no
no no witchcraft craft. Not actively not
not actively going into that. Thank
goodness.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. It's interesting that you brought
all of this up because um you know I
became a Christian when I was 15 16.
That's when I started attending church
and
>> same age as me. Yeah.
>> Yeah. I got baptized 16
>> and you know growing up with all the
Harry Potter we had all of the books in
our house and and I remember I started
like soon after I started attending to
church slash like still when I got
baptized I started seeing
>> a bunch of stuff too like in the middle
of the day I would just like it was like
like we had you know when you have a a
steam shower at home right and you have
a control panel
>> I remember I was just laying in the
bathtub and I was looking at the shower
and I realized that control panel is not
what it looks like and it's not in the
right spot and boop and it went in the
right spot and I was like what? Like
weird things like that that my mom
saying like you know we're getting ready
for church and and I'm standing way over
here. I'm drying my hair. She's over
here and she turns around. She's like
did you touch me? I'm like no like like
>> getting her chair shaking in the church
and stuff and there's no one around
that's touching her. Things like that.
And and church members told us the
elders said you need to burn your books.
And I thought I was like that's a bit
weird to me, you know, but I was like
sure I guess. And I ended up burning the
books. I had this big African mask from
like the native Africans from South
Africa which they say they sometimes can
cast spells on. So I like you know threw
that out and that's I don't know did you
do something similar to that like throw
things out or burn things or
>> so we became pregnant after years and
years of you know not having any luck
and then funnily enough and after after
we we felt convicted to you know stop
being lukewarm and let's go all in and
started focusing on our on our health
and ourselves and our relationship with
God next month we were pregnant right
>> wow
>> and so that because that's a that's a
whole testimony there. But I when I was
pregnant and I could feel like this
baby, I want this baby to grow up in
light, not in darkness. I remember
>> crying about it. You know, the hormones
didn't help because I was emptying out
this bookshelf.
>> And I told my husband, I don't want this
baby to know any of this darkness. I
want them to be light. But all I kept
worrying about the friends that I might
lose because we were, you know, reading
this together. And there's that
camaraderie like what are we going to
talk about?
>> And so um but no we're still friends but
but it's we definitely so I definitely
started um you know pouring through the
books and they they could tell there was
a change because I started giving them
the books. Um and I said I'm gonna I'm
gonna sell these. And then some of them
were so bad I'm like I'm just gonna put
them in the trash. And now looking back
on it, I just wish I threw them in a bin
and put gas on them and lit them on fire
because
>> roast your marshmallows on them.
>> Yes. I didn't, you know, if I didn't
want to consume them, then why why am I
giving them away? And so I Yeah. So I I
I gave them away and I didn't once not
get sleep paralysis if I was pregnant.
>> Wow. Wow. And so, and you know how we
were talking about this before, um, uh,
several years ago when Austin, because
this has been going on forever,
>> and I've been friends with Alex for a
long time.
>> Um, I think Austin mentioned this to
you.
>> Yeah. and he started talking to me about
it and I told you you know like the only
way I could get myself out of the sleep
paralysis it was either go into lucid
dreaming which is very hard but I was I
was at one point so desperate how do I
get out of sleep paralysis so that's
when I started reading and watching
YouTube videos about people using lucid
dreaming just to get out of it but
there's also some
>> now how do you how do you even get into
that how do you force yourself to dream
>> I'm I'm not Sure, but it happened twice.
I I was able to do that twice. But the
other way I could get out of um sleep
paralysis was
>> cursing the lady or this this figure
like making it like if I could be so
overcome with anger, then I can stop it.
>> And remember what you told me, your
advice? You remember what you told me?
>> I think I told you that you should pray
about it.
>> Yes. Yeah.
>> And you know what I told you?
>> I can't remember. I said, "Alex,
whenever I pray, it gets madder."
>> I do remember you saying that. Yes.
>> And it's so and it's even scarier
because at one point I remember so I
started re I started um I I was kind of
halfway, you know, I was reading my my
Bible and I was reading these books and
then I would get sleep paralysis and I
would have this, you know, shadowy
figure and I started I would pray.
Sometimes you can't close your eyes when
you're in sleep paralysis.
>> Um, but I would pray. I'm like, you
know, in the name of Jesus, get out. Get
out. Get out. It shook me.
>> Oh, wow.
>> It shook me like in like in my in my in
in my dream. I was getting shaken
because I was so mad at me. But, you
know, I was probably still laying, you
know, flat on the bed, right?
>> But so, I stopped. And I was talking
about this with a friend last night. I
said, you know, the prayers never
worked. And he said, "Well, maybe it
never worked because God couldn't reach
you because you surrounded yourself
willingly with the devil."
>> So like you had to get the books out of
your life.
>> Yes. And so and and so that that was
this was a conversation last night and I
was thinking about what you said. That
bookshelf that I had that was full of
these books were literally next to me in
the bedroom.
>> Yeah. So it's like an invitation.
>> They have a right to be in your space.
There was a an old
>> um kind of he worked for the
Bilderberers which is like a secret
society and um he was like from one of
these old families that this comes from
from like Europe and stuff and one of
the tasks that they put him to was to be
he was a witch a male witch and I think
they call it a warlock I think
but um they had him as the um person
overseeing the capital records like if
you ever seen the picture in Los Angeles
of that really round building and it's
his capital record like you get
destroyed in a lot of like you know end
of the world movies and stuff.
>> Um and there's an altar in the top of
the uh Capital Records and in the 70s
every single band that was part of the
Capital Records they would take the
master of that and they would bring it
into the altar room and they would pray
that demonic spirits would go with every
single copy of these records
>> and he would say that if you want to
know how many demons are in your home,
go count your records.
And it's interesting because when we
share literature to go out and
evangelize, right, we ask that God will
go with this book or that go out there.
They're doing the same thing, right?
>> And and so yeah, when you have these
things in your house, they're in your
space next to you, it's like that
demon's like, "Hey, I got I got rights
to this thing." And what's fascinating,
too, is hearing you say this today. Just
today I'm sitting there in my my front
and I hear this like guy walking around
in our halls at our studio and he's like
hey hey anybody here and uh and I walked
around and and he was wearing like a
farmer's insurance shirt
>> and and I was like can I help you? And
he said oh you know I'm in a business
that's like down the street a little bit
but I had some packages that that FedEx
said that they dropped off here and it
was like the wrong address but somehow
it was here and he they didn't write
which unit it was on or whatever like
that. So he was trying to find these
packages and then he was like super
curious like what are you guys doing in
this building?
>> Probably saw the YouTube plaque that we
have
>> or whatever, you know. Yeah. So I was
like, "Oh, we're we're Christian
YouTubers and we make, you know, YouTube
videos and stuff like that." And he was
like, "Oh, that's really fascinating."
So I went in the back to try and ask
everybody else if they had seen this
these packages that this person was
looking for. And as we're walking
around, we went through our like little
CG room and stuff like this. And I was
talking to one of the CG guys and and
and I go he was working on something
about Demon Hunters.
>> K-pop Demon Hunters. K-pop Demon
Hunters.
>> I've heard of it. Yeah. My friend just
asked me if I watched it and I politely
said, "I will never."
>> So So what was really interesting is he
he turns to me immediately when I go,
"We're doing something on K-pop Demon
Hunters." And he goes, "Oh man, I got
teenage daughters and they just love
this thing and it bothers me." And so
then I was like, "Oh well, yeah, it's
super demonic." and and I kind of
launched into this little thing. Well,
immediately then he goes, "So, you guys
are you guys are YouTubers and what and
what's the kind of context that you talk
about?" And I told him, you know, we
talk about the spiritual warfare and
media and things like that, right?
>> And he goes, "So, I grew up in a
Christian household that for some reason
my parents wanted to do a seance when I
was a kid."
>> And he said, he vaguely, I mean, I mean,
distinctly, not vaguely, distinctly
remembers, they lit candles, they got
out Ouija boards, they brought all this
stuff together. And he said things were
floating around the room. Candles were
flickering on and off and like and like
the smoke was going into forms and like
walking around the room and stuff like
this. And then he said that since that
night, I think he said he was around 11
or something like this. I think if I
remember the the conversation quickly,
>> a shadowy figure would mess with them
and him and all of his brothers, every
single so often this thing would show up
and torture them. And it he described it
like they would lay on the bed on top of
him and they would tickle him, but it
wasn't a tickle in like haha funny. He
couldn't laugh. He couldn't cry. He
couldn't scream. A paralysis exactly
like what you're saying. Goodness. And
he said that it went on for years and
the parents ended up selling the house
and the same thing happened to the
people that were there.
>> It's crazy. That is very creepy.
>> And so I was like, can you please come
on our show and talk about this? Yes.
And he said, "Yes,
>> it's very common that they would lay on
you." It's
>> But that's weird that that happened
today and then, you know, and they were
talking.
>> Yeah. And all of a sudden, they were
talking about this and I'm just like,
"What?"
>> No, I looked it up. I looked up a couple
of different things about this, but I
was trying to make sure that I wasn't
going to be seeing images cuz sometimes
before before, you know, I get get rid
of all these books. I told Alex
sometimes just talking about it would
trigger it like the next night.
>> Um and so no when I was reading about
it, they called her the hag
>> and like throughout these cultures like
why is it so uniform? Why is it almost
always some kind of like this feminine
figure, you know?
>> Yeah.
>> Like a witch with a cauldron. Oh, did
you still have the cauldron at this
time?
>> No, I don't. I think I just threw that
away.
>> No, but I mean like when this thing was
showing up, did you have a cauldron?
>> No. Oh, yes I did. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yes, I did have all.
>> So, basically, you had like permission
for it.
>> I had all of the prophecy. No, I didn't
even think about all of these little
toys that in my head were like, haha, so
cute. It made me it made me buy it
because I I it was part of the imagery
of the book, right? It was like
>> So, it it's like um you know, like a
McDonald's. This is the M. This is like
the the the logo for this.
>> But how many people have like a stuffed
dragon or like you know, stuff like this
that's like kind of throwing that but
you know the Bible is so clear like you
read in Exodus um 22:18 it says thou
shalt not suffer a witch to live
>> you know there's this concept in the
Bible that like witchcraft should not be
done what should should not be there
should be no part of it right
>> um and and Saul makes the egregious
error of going to this witch to try and
call up a prophet right
>> and it appears it looks like it's Samuel
the prophet
>> but I got some serious questions. He's
old,
>> right?
>> Like if he died and he went to heaven,
right? And that would have a new body.
>> Why you coming up as old? And then also
like why you coming up from the ground?
>> Exactly. Shouldn't you come up from up
there if that's where you are? Like that
shows a demon.
>> It was a demon that was that was
tricking them.
>> I I think also
>> that Satan tends to sugarcoat
>> Oh yeah.
>> this kind of stuff. So So like you were
talking talking about Harry Potter world
for example, right? Well, some people
might not go to Harry Potter because
maybe that's still too like, oh, it's
too close to it as a Christian.
>> Please bring up Mickey Mouse.
>> That's true. Original Mickey Mouse is a
wizard. But
>> Oh, okay. Didn't know that.
>> Sorcerers apprentice.
>> He wanted to be the sorcerer's
apprentice. That was his that was his
Fantasia thing. Put the thing on there
and then he made the like broom go over
and do his work.
>> So, every little kid is going around
with those little ears.
>> It's a magician. M
>> but also things like like I used to be
very addicted to YouTube and praise God
he helped me overcome that and really
changed my life around. But I remember I
was watching YouTubers that were just
traveling from Australia actually and
they would go to Harry Potter World. In
my mind I was thinking like something
told me like you shouldn't be watching
people do this kind of stuff. But I was
like, "Yeah, but you know, like I'm not
there." But but you know, like the Bible
talks about by beholding we become
changed, right? And and so and don't uh
what's the scripture say that you're not
supposed to take pleasure in those doing
evil?
>> Yeah. Actually, Romans 1:32, it says uh
who knowing the judgment of God, that
they which commit such things are worthy
of death, not only do the same, but have
pleasure in them that do them. So, yeah,
exactly what you're talking about.
>> Yeah. And so it it is really sugar coat
like Wicked, the movie Wicked that blew
up and so many Christians went to see
Wicked, but I mean if you really dig
into Wicked, like we have a couple of
shows on our channel that we did about
it and one of them are our our co-host
Keith, he talked about how there's like
serious connections to the cult like
Madame Bllovsky and Alice A. Bailey.
>> Um there serious connections to the
LGBTQ being fully pushed and wicked. But
that's but those are all separate issues
in the Bible besides witchcraft, right?
That God's like, "Stay away from these
things."
>> Deuteronomy 18:10 through12 is is I
think one of the really strong languages
that the Bible uses to not be involved
in witchcraft, you know, um that should
not be found among you, anyone that has
his son or his daughter and move or pass
through the fire, uses divination or
channeling or consulting with familiar
spirits or necromancy for all these
things that all that do these things are
an abomination to God. And that word
abomination, when you really look that
up, it's like God just hates this thing
because it's turning people away from
him.
>> And if you really distill down to what
what is it what is it actually that God
hates about witchcraft? Like what like
why is he so animosity towards it?
Because what is it that he actually
hates? And and if you see something
supernatural like like what magic would
do, right? Like all of a sudden if you
just went bonk and something happened,
right? If you can't explain that in the
real world, you really only have two
ways to look at that thing that happened
that's unexplainable by the natural
world.
>> You'd have to say either God did it or
what magic does is it takes the magic
power away or the it takes the creative
power I should say away from God and it
now puts it in your hand. If I mix the
right potion, if I do say the right
words together, if I do the right thing,
now I'm causing the outcome of that
thing. And that's why I think each of
the cultures, Egypt, all those ones that
were heavily involved in witchcraft and
sorcery and all this, it was like they
were trying to perform these things that
God alone is able to do. And now all of
a sudden, Satan's going, "See, I can do
that, too, and that's taking the power
away." And what did that ultimately do?
That's why when you look at how Moses
confronting Pharaoh, throwing down his
rod, and the snakes are sitting there
um, you know, coming out of it and the
magicians are, "Well, we can do that,
too." and they throw their snakes down
and they do it cuz they're using magic
and sorcery. What does the Bible say
right there? It says they that Pharaoh
hardened his heart. Why? Because Oh, you
think that's magic? Like, look at what I
can do. Look at what my sorcerers can
do. And so, what it really does is it
breaks your trust in God.
>> Yeah. And I believe that.
>> And that's why I think when you're
reading those kind of things,
>> I almost I I almost want to ask the
serious question like, were you guys
interested in reading this?
>> Not at the time.
>> Not at the time. No. And so I I I
remember a relative asking me that
specifically because I had a package for
this book that I never really um read,
thank goodness, another thing that had
demons, you know, in it.
>> But he asked me, "Oh, that's a really
cool book. You have a lot of books. Do
you read your Bible?" And I said, "Oh,
shut up.
>> Yeah, you Bible thumper."
>> But in my head at that time, you know,
you know, I can read that whenever. It's
always there, right? But no, the more
that I felt like I need to read this,
not just for me, but but for my child
really, I really didn't want him to be
surrounded by by this darkness, which is
another thing, you know, that's another
thing that I read very recently. It's
almost like in preparation for this.
This is before our conversation is that
first John um one verse 6, it was
talking about light and darkness
>> and you know, God is light and
>> in him is no darkness at all, no
darkness at all. And so I, you know, if
I surrounded myself with that, I
probably would, I probably would have
sleep paralysis again because I haven't
had it. Now, I I did, I will say, um,
very recently I had it, um, where I was
paralyzed for a couple of minutes and
then I was able to move myself out of
it, but there wasn't any kind of
malevolence.
>> There was no darkness there.
>> There was no darkness. There was no
darkness. There was no, you know, shadow
lady um, in one corner of the room.
There wasn't that fear. It was just
like, "Oh, I'm paralyzed." Fascinating.
I haven't had this in a while. And then
I got myself out of it.
>> Well, I I think I think that it it takes
a while, too, for the demons to hear
over and over again like, "No, she's no
longer with us."
>> Like, do you know about Roger Monno?
>> Very very Yeah.
>> So, he was um he was a Satanist.
>> Oh, yes. and full on was, you know, into
that demon call in up in Montreal
>> and he was about to do his initiation, I
think, and then left and became a
Christian. But he says shares in his
testimony that yeah, for years after
that, they still were able to
>> torment him,
>> torment him, but he just trusting God
and, you know, believes in Jesus and and
same thing with we had this lady,
actually we she was on your channel,
too. We did a, you know, we share the
record here, share in our channel just
like, you know, we're going to do with
this one. But, um, she she had the same
thing. She, her father was a high voodoo
priest and and all the celebrities and
famous people came and visited her
father to make sacrifices to Satan. And
he would even tell those people, "This
is what you're supposed to write in your
lyrics and all that kind of stuff."
>> So, she was going to be groomed to be
the next one in line after he passed
away. And yeah, like once she got out of
that, it was years for her. The same
thing that the demons tormented her, but
she said the thing that really
solidified this, it it was reading the
scriptures out loud.
>> And and just believing like, "No, these
are the promises of God in scripture.
This is real. I am saved. I am set free.
They can't control me anymore." And then
it all stopped.
>> That's faith.
>> Yeah. It's faith.
>> Yeah.
>> I think it's because they're they're
they're complete liars.
>> Yeah. and and everything that comes out
of their mouth is lying. They're just
going to lie and do whatever they, you
know, they're they're designed to do.
And so when they hear the very truth,
>> it's like they hate it because it's like
the opposite of what they are.
Everything that they do is just this
complete lie.
>> Heartbreak.
>> You might experience something similar
this year, hearing those familiar words,
>> trickor treat. But instead of giving
them a trick or a treat, give them
truth. Get our new sharing cards on
spiritualism and witchcraft and give
them something better.
I think of Isaiah 8:1 19. It says, "And
when they shall say unto you, seek unto
them that have familiar spirits, and
unto wizards that peep and that mutter,
should not a people seek unto their God,
for the living to the dead,
>> to the law, and to the testimony, if
they speak not according to this word,
it is because there is no light in
them."
>> Yeah.
>> So, that's a good verse. The reason why
I think we see so much spiritualism here
in the end of time, and it's like seems
like it's ramping up, right? I mean, I
don't know. I I I I didn't grow up on a
ton of TV, I guess. But now, doesn't it
just seem like they're serious?
>> It's just so easy to disperse that
media. Yeah.
>> It's pervasive now. It's in everything,
>> and it's getting the the audience is
getting younger and younger,
>> right? You know what I mean? And it's
like, wow, these these these poor kids
have no idea like what's really behind
these layers. But but we know that
Satan's going to come out in the open.
We know that, right? He's going to to um
mimic a coming of Christ or a cosmic
Christ or
>> Matthew 24 warns us of that. There shall
be arise false Christ and false prophets
and they shall deceive many. There's
going to be great signs and wonders that
if it were possible shall come as an
angel of light.
>> Yeah.
>> So he's got to prep everybody with all
this spiritualism stuff.
>> You see priming the pump. You you see it
like I was going through my work and
there was a one of the the managers had
her office closed and there was a there
was a a sign on and it says the witch is
in
>> and like you know you see that like on
bumper stickers you'll see like people
that have like a broom a broom handle
you know on their like bumper bumper
sticker and like there's
>> where is that from? What is that
referring to? Is that
>> I I don't know. There's just like
>> the witches fly the witch's Yeah. And so
there's like so many different little
snippets from like different things that
are all referring to witchcraft.
>> That's so normal.
>> It's so normalized in today's like
there's a there's a house that's fairly
close to my house.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Uh that when you drive by it, they have
like every single uh uh yard ornament
that you can buy. Like you know you go
to like Home Depot and they have like
those yard ornaments.
>> They have like every single one of them
out there.
>> Why do people want to have that around
them? because it's a celebration of
death. It is what it is. It is. And I
used to dress up for that, you know,
because it was just like, oh, you know,
you're just dressing up. I'm not doing
any kind of demonic stuff. And it's just
a dress up. Like one year, I dressed up
as
>> I don't know, Mulan.
>> And I was just thinking that is this is
this is benign. This is just for work.
There is nothing evil about it. I am not
going out trick-or-treating. So in my
head, I thought it was okay. This is
okay. Just like the books that I'm
reading, they're just okay. But the more
you read about it, the more you're
convicted, like I I can't do this. I
can't be with light and dark. I gota I
gotta pick something.
>> This is true.
>> And so, yeah. Now, I I look at that and
I laugh. But in my head, I'm like, I
really don't want this around me. Or
>> I don't even want my child to say,
"Mommy, what's that for?" You know, why
is that? Why do we celebrate this?
>> You know, and then you have to explain
it like, "Yeah, this is why people have
dead people in their backyard, you
know?"
Yes.
>> If you're a Christian and and you really
truly just look at the simplicity of
what is it what is it that you're
actually looking at if you like death,
right?
>> Jesus had to come down and die.
>> Yeah.
>> Like he came down from heaven and was
killed.
>> Mhm.
>> That he laid down his life and and it's
like it's like somebody had to take that
sin of the entire world. But think about
how many people have lost loved ones
because of death. M
>> how many times that I mean we we don't
want this anymore.
>> Yeah. We're celebrating it in such a fun
cutesy candy way.
>> Exactly. Exactly. And it's like such a
twisted view of like, you know, do you
think God's up there smiling and going,
I'm I'm so glad that they have a
skeleton in their face.
>> Well, you know, you know, it's actually
it's not just like in secular society
that you see the celebration of death.
You actually can see it even in in the
roots of Catholicism
because
>> like a death cult. Yeah. And they well
they have uh momento mori actually.
Absolutely. Which is the saying like uh
you know basically
>> remember you will die.
>> Yeah. Remember you will die. And there's
like a um Jonathan room who played in
the chosen actually he has like a ring
that shows like a skull you know.
>> Yeah. Two of them.
>> Um and uh and you guys have a whole
episode actually talking about the
chosen and talking about Jonathan Ry
which is really good. Um, but it shows
like he has this it's like almost like
this fascination with like skulls and
>> that type thing
>> and and I understand where they're
coming from because they're they're
explaining it as and by the way momentum
is also used by the Freemasons just FYI
there's an overlap there but they they
explain it as like yeah remember you
will die like live today to your best
for God because someday you will die and
that's an honorable thing but I I guess
>> I don't think God like I believe as
Christians we should remember,
you know, live every single day to the
best for God because we talk about
sometimes like, you know, like we don't
know when our when, you know, you might
get hit by a bus tomorrow, you know.
>> Um,
>> but the problem is when it gets
connected to like the Freemasonry and
the thing and like, you know, I don't
believe that God wants us to be walking
around with skulls and death symbols and
that kind of stuff. Like he wants us to
celebrate
>> Jesus second coming and that he's coming
soon to take us all home. And that's the
reason we choose every day to live for
God.
>> But how weird is it that the guy that's
playing Jesus has these death symbols on
him so that when you're looking at him,
you're looking at the very savior of
life that in him is life. And there is
like, you know, there's no death in him
kind of a thing, right? It's it's it's
in him is the life. And here the guy
that's branding that picture of Jesus in
everybody's mind is like wearing death.
It's such a weird juosition. Well, you
know, I always think of 1 Thessalonians
4:17. Then we which are alive and remain
shall be caught up together with them in
the clouds to meet the Lord in the air,
and so shall we ever be with the Lord.
So, there's going to be a group of
people at the end of time before like
when Christ comes back
>> that when he comes in the clouds of
glory, they're alive and they're caught
up to meet him and they never see death.
>> Yep.
>> And so, we can look at momentum and
like, yeah, you know, no, you know, work
for God because you know that you will
die. Not everyone.
>> Yeah.
>> Enoch didn't. Elijah did.
>> Moses. Moses did and then he was
resurrected.
>> Right.
>> Shouldn't we be encouraged to try and
want to be a part of that that don't see
death,
>> right?
>> Yeah.
>> And then I think a lot of this is
actually the misconception of what death
is.
>> The whole discussion about familiar
spirits, right?
>> Um because there's this there's this
understanding in Catholicism, but also
in a lot of other uh cultures out there
as well.
>> Yes. about what exactly happens when you
die
>> and it's a very interesting discussion.
>> Well, you know, the origins of this idea
of of after you die, you will have a
soul and your soul goes out of your body
and you go to heaven. The origins of
that is actually Greek and and even
beyond that.
>> So, you can actually look this up. It's
it's pure history. started with the
Greeks, you know, got passed down to the
Romans and eventually out of the Roman
group of people came the Roman Catholic
Church, which is means Roman universal
church. And this is no slam on on our
Catholic brothers and sisters because,
you know, I grew up Catholic. You grew
up Catholic.
>> There's no slam on that at all. This is
I'm just trying to explain what the
reality of it is. is that Roman
Catholicism at the time when you really
studied the history it was a blending of
Christianity with paganism. The paganism
from the Romans
>> blending with Christianity and so there
were still a group of Christians that
was passed down through the generations
that still kept the word of God as it
stands true. Some light got lost, some
light was given later on generations
later kind of came back from the
scriptures. But yeah, it's a blending of
paganism with Christianity. And so that
idea as well of like purgatory, eternal
hellfire, and that you have some kind of
a soul being inside of you that's going
to come out and that's going to either
go to hell or to heaven or as
Protestants believe now, no, they're
going to go, you know, to heaven after
you die.
>> Or you get stuck. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Or you get stuck or you go walk
around. What whatever people believe in
Christianity today, that's actually not
biblical. It's coming from paganism that
got blended with some Christianity down
the road.
>> Well, you know, let's look at this
logically, right?
>> When Jesus comes again, he's coming to
raise people from the dead. So, if
everybody that's going to be raised up
and like go into the sky in the change
in the twinkle of the eye, um there's
probably a little bit of a moment that
when you get raised or I don't know,
maybe it's like that twinkles before,
but it seems like it's happening as
you're getting raised up, right? So just
explain the logic of this. You've been
living in heaven for, you know,
thousands of years or whatever because
you died way in the anti-dolivian world,
but you love Jesus and or love God and
so you're you're you're in heaven.
>> Yeah.
>> And then it's like, okay, we're going to
go get our everybody down there. Uh I'm
going to go back down to my body and
it's like, oh man, this is what it was
like to be old and now I'm not.
>> That's actually really true.
Do you know one of the the main things
that you can look at is actually just
the death of Lazarus
>> or any of the other people that was that
were resurrected. Okay, so let's just
imagine this. Lazarus was called the
friend of Jesus. So if Lazarus is Jesus'
friend, we can assume he was probably
going to the good place. Most people
would would come to that conclusion.
Okay, so um Jesus goes to the tomb. He
doesn't call him down. He's not like,
"Hey, come on down from the clouds."
He's like, he goes to the tomb.
>> Come out.
>> And he's like, "Come out." Right,
Lazarus, come out. Right. And uh so
Lazarus comes out. Why would Lazarus not
come out and be like,
>> "Man,
>> yeah. What? I'm in these in these like
death clothes again. Like I'm in this
mortal body. I have to walk this earth
again." Like
>> I was already in heaven.
>> I was already up there like on the
streets of gold. Like I mean I was
getting good on the harp, dude. You
Yeah. I'm like down and it's four days,
but I mean it's four days. And so then
I've had some people explain it and say,
"Well, that's because Christ, you know,
he didn't go anywhere because Christ
hadn't died yet. Christ and so that
atonement hadn't been completed." And so
I've had some Christians tell me this.
They say, "Well, you know, he didn't go
anywhere because um specifically because
Christ hadn't died on the cross yet."
And so I was like, "Okay, well then how
about all the people that were
resurrected?"
>> Elijah, Moses,
>> sure, there's those, but those are still
before the cross. And so they'll say,
"Okay, anybody before the anybody before
the cross, they didn't go anywhere." And
so then I'm like, "Well, what about all
the c the resurrections after the cross
of which there were multiple."
>> You had the man that fell out of the
window that Paul was preaching and he
falls out and he rises from the dead.
Why isn't he like, "Man, I was just
seeing it and you guys snatched me back
down here."
>> Yep. There's um examples. Yeah, for
sure.
>> And you know, I look at it from a
medicine standpoint. Um, and you know,
we actually in uh in surgery when we
when we're putting somebody under for
anesthesia, they actually put a monitor
on their forehead. It has these little
stickies and it goes on there. It's
called a biz monitor
>> and you plug it in and it's a brain wave
monitor basically and you're monitoring
their essentially their neur neuronal
activity in their brain and you use it
for kind of guiding anesthesia. So, it's
like a it's like a okay, if there's less
activity there, the anesthetic is
probably working pretty good. Now, it's
not the only thing that they use.
There's a whole science behind
anesthesia, but um what happens when you
go under surgery? You fall asleep,
>> you wake up, there's no dream or
anything. You just wake up
>> and some amount of time has passed and
to your recollection, your knowledge,
nothing has happened or you're just in a
different place, right? You're in the
recovery room.
>> Yeah.
>> What happens when you go to sleep at
night?
>> Yeah. Same sort of
>> you wake up. You might have a dream. Of
course, we do know there is some
activity in your brain
>> because you're alive.
>> Yeah. Because you're alive. And there
there can be quite a bit of activity
there.
>> Unless you have Harry Potter books in
your room.
>> Yes. And you're not sleeping.
>> Then you're not happily sleeping. But
but basically there's this there's this
scientific standpoint. Neuronal activity
is what really means there's
consciousness. You think about the case.
Have you heard of the case of Phineas
Gage?
>> Yeah. Yeah. He was a railroad worker and
he was working on the railroad and he
hit something and there's this piece of
steel that or iron or whatever that went
through like his jaw I think
>> and it it went out the top of his
frontal lobe and it destroyed his memory
it or all kinds of different things
because it
>> became a different person.
>> Yeah, he became a different person. So I
always ask people I'm like okay
>> so in that analogy
what was injured? Was it his body or was
it his soul?
>> Because his whole personality everything
else changes.
>> Yeah. And so from a scientific
standpoint, well, his body was changed,
but then his personality changed.
>> So we have to link consciousness with
the body.
>> That's right.
>> And that's why I think in Genesis 2:7
when it says God formed uh man of the
dust of the ground and breathed into his
nostrils the breath of life and man
became a living soul,
>> a living being.
>> So you have two independent parts that
are coming together. You have man formed
from the dust of the ground,
>> dirt,
>> and then you have the breath of God
that's breathed into his nostrils. And
together you have what a soul is. A soul
isn't some like ethereal floating, you
know, extra coraporeal, you know,
fantasy type thing. The Bible never
describes it that way. It describes it
as the combination of the breath of God
>> and dirt that God formed.
>> Yep. That's why Larry Pageige from
Google and all those guys that have been
trying to solve death and and mix this
whole stuff with AI and figure out how
to download the consciousness and and
Elon Musk trying to make everybody, you
know, like bend towards this idea of
this neurolink and stuff like that. It's
not going to happen. What they're trying
to do is download your consciousness so
that they can put it on some piece of
hardware that they can just update down
the road and and continue you on. That's
really what they're trying to do.
>> Oh, yeah. But the thing is, you know
what they're missing? They're missing
the breath of God.
>> Yeah. Yes. And they're missing the dirt.
>> Oh, they're missing both. Yeah. Yeah.
So, you don't got nothing.
>> They're looking for eternity in a
different place
>> with no consequences. They're looking
for a way out of the consequences.
>> So, when you really understand that
concept of the breath of God, you know,
there's verses like I I'll read this one
to you. Job 34:14-15. If he should set
his heart on it, if he should gather to
himself his spirit and his breath, all
flesh would perish together. and man
would return to dust. Psalm 146:4, his
spirit departs. He returns to his earth
in that very day his plans perish. Uh in
Ecclesiastes 12:7, then the dust will
return to the earth as it was, and a
spirit will return to God who gave it.
So this is where people think, oh, well,
there's a spirit, which means that
there's a soul, right? But in many of
these verses, when you read the actual
original Hebrew, it's like ruins
breath. It actually means breath of God
because God breathes into Adam's
nostrils the breath of life.
>> So breath is equal, it's a simple
equation. Breath plus dust or dirt
equates
a living being,
>> right?
>> A living being minus God's breath of
life minus, you know, your I guess your
body dies as well equates nothing. Like
you just go back to the to the dirt of
the earth. And you know, it's
interesting too, you were referencing um
let me look it up here. 1 Thessalonians
4:13 and 14, right?
>> And so toward the end there, it says
this is talking about the second coming
of Jesus. And it says, "If we believe
that Jesus died and rose again, even so
God will bring with him those who sleep
in Jesus."
>> So I've had a lot of people challenge me
like, "Oh, well, soul sleep as that's
kind of like the words being thrown
around isn't biblical." But but you
know, you just mentioned Lazarus is
dead, but he's also equated to being
asleep. In this case there, it's saying
that those who believe and trust in
Jesus are asleep until he comes. I'm not
I don't think that Adam is sleeping
right now. He's dead. Lazarus is dead,
right? Um and the same with let me see
over here.
>> The word sleep is used to describe death
like something like 52 times in the
Bible. There's like a it's like so and
so died and slept with his father. So
and so or so and so slept with his
fathers. It it uses that word sleep,
sleep, sleep, sleep over and over and
over. But then, you know, you have
Ecclesiastes 9:5. For the living know
that they shall die, but the dead know
not anything. Neither have they any more
reward for the memory of them is
forgotten.
>> Yep.
>> So, you know, you have this this concept
over and over repeated that once you
die, there's no memory, there's no
knowledge until you're resurrected.
>> That's what Thessalonians says,
>> right? And there's that verse also that
talks about um blessed is he that hath
part in the first resurrection
>> and not the second. So we know there's
two different resurrections. That's
getting into a whole different
discussion about that. But at the same
time
>> that resurrection that takes place that
>> is when you have conscious thought
again.
>> Mhm.
>> So if I'm alive now which I think I'm
alive. I think
>> if I'm alive
>> and I die.
>> Yeah. And there's like is there a
crossover in that logic of like well I'm
going either up or down or whatever that
is right um um so is there like well I
got to sleep for 24 hours and then I go
up or down right so I'm asking you some
logical questions here that if I'm live
right now and I go to go to somewhere
and I go somewhere else but I'm still
alive where did I die
>> like in what what is death then because
you didn't describe death to me at all
if I'm still living. I'm just somewhere
else, but I'm not in this thing. I'm
just like out there. It's like there was
no death in my spirit, so to say, if you
would say that you had a spirit like
that.
>> Well, so there's actually um a statement
where I ask people this. I'll say, "Can
a soul die?" And I'll have people people
tell me, "No, no, no, no. A soul can't
die. The Bible says it can."
>> And literally, that is direct verbatim
quote.
>> The soul that sinnth it shall die.
>> Yeah. And also Jesus said, you know, do
not be afraid of the one that can, you
know, take your body, but be the one
that can take your body and your soul.
>> And Romans 6:23, for the wages of sin is
death, but the gift of God is eternal
life in Christ Jesus our Lord. So if
there is some kind of a hell burning
right now, and you have some soul that
goes into the hell or purgatory,
but the gift of eternal life is for
those who, you know, love Jesus.
>> Yeah.
>> Then then you're burning in hell
forever. But the gift is not supposed to
be for you, but you're living forever,
>> right?
>> So, so bringing this all back to this
discussion about some of this fantasy
stuff that is so prevalent in today's
society, bringing it all back to the the
witches, the wizards, all that type
stuff. The one thing that a lot of that
stuff has in common is is a discussion
of the afterlife.
>> Yes.
>> Oh, yes. Yeah.
>> Is talking about basically what happens
when you die. Even in Harry Potter,
there's very clearly in the last couple
books a discussion about the afterlife.
>> Yes. Because one of um a very special
character to the main character passed
away. And so there's this question like,
"Oh, but where did he go? Can I go
access him later on, you know,
>> and did they answer that?"
>> Oh, they did. Harry Harry actually in
the movies goes and he speaks to the
main wizard which is Dumbledore and he
goes and finds him kind of in this it's
sort of like the afterlifeish kind of
it's like they describe it as a train
station
>> but uh goes I think it's a train station
but uh goes and talks to him and so he's
communing
>> with the dead
>> and and um
>> Bible speaks against necromancy.
>> Yes. And and Harry in in in the in it
says he actually asks the main
character. He's like um you know this is
all in my mind. Is this is isn't this
just all in my mind this discussion? And
the the the the ancient wizard
Dumbledore says of course it's in your
mind but that doesn't mean it's not any
less true.
>> And it's like man like what kind of
message is that telling to all these you
know you know you go to um
>> Barnes & Noble. Yeah. You go to like any
major book place that's Harry Potter
section
>> there's a and and who are they gearing
it towards
>> children
>> and and did you know that they have the
real books sitting right next to it?
Have you ever actually like went through
there and looked and there's like
there's like real like witchcrafty
looking
>> right next to the books that they that
they made up in the the Harry Potter
world she made into actual books that
you could buy
>> spell books and stuff learn how to
spell. It's it's interesting too
whenever you get into the books um the
the world that she made is so full of
different kinds of creatures that's
pulled from different um different
countries mythology. So there's some
Greek mythology there, you know, there's
some there's some go yes, there's
there's all these different kinds of
creatures that's pulled from from um
from mythology that seem so benign. Some
of them are helpful and then some of
them are quite evil. But um some of the
newer books right now there is just
absolutely no no way that you can
discern that this is bad when the actual
villains in the book are supposed to be
angels and then you're reading all these
other books
>> where the the the the main character is
literally the devil. You know, because
there's so much the hero, there's so
much longing for this anti-hero, at
least in my generation, you know, where
they they want they want the man who
would burn the city just to save you.
Like that's the kind of love that
they're longing for, but it's not good,
you know? It's there's it's just it's
it's quite
>> it's a reversal of how God works
>> of how I was just thinking that God gave
up his life for you and yet you're
looking for a man who would kill
everyone else to save you cuz for some
reason that's romantic
>> and so that's it's it's quite pervasive
in all the books that I read in all the
collections there's so many of them and
as such such an avid reader I would read
one or two books you know in a week and
I would just consume and then you get
this sense sensitized to all of these
the the violence and the creatures and
all the stuff that they're saying and
there's so much um malevolence in some
of them too. Um but yeah, you get
desensitized to it that you're just
looking for and more and more exciting.
>> Did you ever read His Dark Materials?
>> No,
>> that was um the ones that they did the
Golden Compass and
>> Oh yes, that was when I was a teenager.
Yeah, I've never I've never read those.
>> Never read those. The ending of I think
it was a trilogy. I'm not sure because
um but um um the ending story is exact.
>> Is that the one with the demons? The d
the demons.
>> They they have I believe a character
that they called the um the um almighty
or no it was like it was like something
that they were clearly talking about god
>> and the majesty. That's what it was or
something like this. And basically that
was going to come and destroy the people
and because um they wouldn't follow
along and do whatever it was asking them
to do and stuff like this. And when you
listen to the final scene, the BBC
actually made a a movie about how that
was a you know live action kind of
movie.
>> And in that final scene, I mean, it's
like you're watching the end scene of
Satan give everybody a pep talk to fight
against God. I mean, it sounds like he's
just literally like picking up at the
Bible at Revelation 20 and like, you
know, going, "Let's rally the troops.
He's coming. He's right there. And we're
not going to follow you." He's called
the great authority. That's what it was.
>> And he's like, "We're not going to
worship and bow down to the great
authority anymore. We're free and we're
going to die in our freedom." And you
know, it's like
>> there's so much cheap piracy of God and
and literature. It's it's
>> and you think about what that's planting
into a child's mind. And I always say
this, what's the best way to teach a
child about God? You tell them a bunch
of stories.
>> In fact, that's how we start when you
have a baby. Read them the stories of
Noah. Read them the stories of Jonah.
Read them the stories of the more that
they read those things. And then the
more detail that's added to that as they
get older, they understand the world of
God, right? And so the devil's doing
that same thing. He's just giving them a
bunch of stories. And all those stories
are just adding more detail. But it's
like about the opposite of that. Let's
save this planet here. Let's build our
kingdom here. Anything that's coming in
the sky, we're going to fight against
that thing right there. And it's like
they're just planting seeds.
>> And then you have the the stories like
like what's going on in Harry Potter and
stuff that talks about the dead, talks
about
>> that they're actually alive and that you
should communicate with them. So I think
>> that's basically I maybe the core of
what we're saying here is that one, it
lets demons into your life, you know,
like what happened to you and I think it
happened to me as well. I I know demons
were, you know, harassing me and I'm
sure it has a lot to do with the books
that I was reading as well and the
movies that I was watching.
>> But then on top of that, it's teaching
you a false kind of theology. It's
teaching you that the dead can speak to
you. And in some cases, you know, it's
it's the dead the dead are your friends
and you should go and hang out with
them. And in some other cases, they are
demonic, but then they have power over
you and all those things. When Jesus
made all of these angels who
unfortunately rebelled against him in
heaven when the war happened in heaven
and fell and were cast out, he made them
good at the time with you know that he
they have free will to decide
>> who to worship.
>> But since he is the creator and he is
the savior and he's a king of kings and
lord of lords, they can't do anything
against the name of Jesus. You know, he
has the power. But they don't want you
to believe that.
>> Yeah. You know, it goes even deeper
though because think about Harry Potter
and again I I listened audiobook form to
the entire series probably twice
actually and it's a lot there's a lot of
content there
>> but and so I I know a lot about it.
>> One of the main things that's pushed in
this is the the um villain in the whole
series.
>> Voldemort.
>> Is it Voldemort or Voldemort?
>> Voldemort. The main villain in the
entire series though, the way that he's
so powerful, the way that he's so like
>> able to come back from like the very
brink
>> is because it goes to the soul.
>> Oh yeah.
>> He splits his soul. And so they they
define and into seven pieces.
>> Seven horruxes.
>> Yeah. In seven horcruxes. So
>> why does it have to be seven?
>> Exactly. Why seven? But but again it's
it's trying to define for the reader
what is a soul, you know. Yeah.
>> And so if you can split it, if you can
divide it, well then it's not the
biblical soul, right?
>> And so it's spread. And that's that's
the the main thing of how they're
finally able to defeat him as they have
to go track down all these different
portions of his soul.
>> And it's like what a deception to try
and plant in young minds is to try and
twist the understanding of what a soul
is. You think a a young person's going
to walk away from that and think that
anything other than that is true as far
as like a soul being separate from the
body?
>> Mhm.
>> They literally just read a whole
seven-part series about it being
separate from the body.
>> Besides, he looked like a full-on demon.
I was always scared of him.
>> Oh, yes. And they made him they made him
so powerful that even just saying his
name was just you can't even say the
name.
>> And that's that's opposite of the Bible
as well cuz cuz the demons fear the name
of Jesus. And now they show the
opposite.
>> Yes. He who must not be named because
his name is so powerful. Yeah. Just
thinking about that right now.
>> And you know, you you you joke about
that later on when you're when you're a
kid or whatever, you know, he who must
not be named. That's literally the
devil,
>> right?
>> But you don't think about that. It's
just it's just a character with no nos,
you know?
>> But no, when when you get older and you
get more discernment, you you you know,
you you're not going to fall into that
trap. It's that's so um obvious, you
know, good versus evil. But when you're
my age, um you you read other books and
it's it's a lot more
>> it's a lot more confusing.
>> It's a lot more confusing. You know,
that's when that's when you really need
to know what you're what you're getting
into. If you don't have the the
background of reading the Bible, if you
don't have a relationship with Jesus, if
you don't have any relationship with a
God at all, everything you're consuming
is a fair game.
>> Yeah. And then we haven't even talked
about the actors that channel the demons
to play the roles. They haven't even
talked about that yet. That's a whole
other story, but
>> we're going,
>> you know, and I think that that's an
important note is that there's so many
different TV shows and movies out there
that are channelneled writings now. Yep.
where the the authors of these these
different screenplays, different books,
different novels. They're not getting it
from themselves.
>> Many comic books are channeled. We have
a whole documentary about that on our
channel that uh they say it
>> automated writing.
>> Alan Moore openly admitted it. Grant
Morrison, all those guys,
>> you know, you you even have TV shows out
there that are making such a mockery of
Christianity like you have the book uh
the the TV show Lucifer.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> And Lucifer, they actually have like a
scene in that where Jesus is killed by
Lucifer,
>> which you know that would be his
ultimate desire. I mean, that's what he
did on the cross, right? But he would
love to have Jesus die. And they portray
Jesus in like this mockery, like this
kind of whiny character. And then they
have him die and there's like this son
imagery right behind
>> Lucifer during it.
>> Oh, that's I mean like Jesus having the
son is Catholic. But that's interesting.
Gave it to Lucifer. you you'd have to
look at it, but I don't encourage
anybody to watch it because
>> And how did they cast Lucifer? 12 dark
and handsome.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. He's like the the most
likable guy in the whole series.
>> And that's when with a lot of books
that's targeted for for, you know, for
for the young women right now. It's this
new new age, you know, fantastical
stuff. It's always such a likable,
handsome hero that will always have some
kind of darkness to them. and they're
just, you know, and they they get this
woman that's just pure and light. And
it's like, why why do we get so so
>> what's the word?
>> Attracted.
>> Attracted to it because it's such a good
way to to to make you to make you
available for him. Mhm.
>> You know, as we close here, one of the
things that I think is important is um
you know, Halloween comes around once a
year.
>> And I think one of the things that my
church is doing that I think I think a
lot of other churches should do is
rather than celebrating the darkness,
rather than celebrating ghosts and
witches and that type thing, our church,
because you know, actually what else
falls on October 31 is Reformation Day.
Yes, Reformation Day. And so, um, our
church is is instead of having a trunk
or treat where again you're going to
have like that that witchcraft
symbolism, even some people will say,
"Oh, it's so harmless."
>> Yeah.
>> Is there really is can this really just
be harmless?
>> Yeah.
>> Um, but our church is putting on a
celebration for the the Protestant
Reformation.
>> Amen.
>> And I think that that is a very good
healthy alternative to understand our
Christian roots
>> and where we come from and the the
heritage that we have. Um and uh I think
I think that's a much better
alternative. I agree. So